hi I'm Luigi Amundsen and I'm going to
be going undercover on the Internet
this is actually me you may not believe
it but it's actually me okay first stop
Switzer this is from no chance I can say
that name
the handle is crazy so just go with
Laura its Lois happy today today drink
can afford they love this one did he
drink enough water did he have a long
comfy shower and most importantly has he
been coddled today numerous questions in
there am I happy today
yes release date I'm buzzing judge drink
enough water probably not mostly coffee
this morning did I have a long shower
not really I woke up at 4:00 a.m.
I've been coddled today no no I'm not
sure I have next now did you decide to
call the album walls this is from at
Lois sunshine I'd love to have a really
clever answer for this but the reality
is the clock was ticking and either an
album named walls is my favorite song
off the album I thought the concept
behind this song individually is called
so I just didn't think about it too much
and one with walls next one is from kami
what's this song that no matter how many
times you sing it the same first
emotions are still there I'm gonna say
and I covered this recently at one of my
show in Madrid mr. Brightside The
Killers only because that was one of the
first songs that I ever sang live way
before I was in the band so definitely
feels nostalgic singing that case is
from Sofia why are you so obsessed with
28 number well my local club Doncaster
Rovers I was lucky enough to be signed
on their box for a couple of seasons and
their squad number they gave me was 28
which is why I got it out um and this is
from at sunflower though why does he
always do that with his hands that one
yeah maybe it's just a British thing
that is it yeah just as you were growing
up just used to be a way of saying some
it was really funny or really good just
get some of that so
this is from Nicole again I can't say
your handle sorry what place are you
most excited to visit on tour it's a bit
stereotypical I love Barcelona as a city
and I'm looking off to be starting my
tour there so today at the moment I'd
say I'm most excited about science
fiction this one is from bread with
honey okay these hunters are getting
more crazy
are you eating okay no I actually had
nothing to eat since I've been proper
busy well I've got a croissant I think I
mean alright to be first just on busy
days you know eat so much they love it
they love asking these questions you
know I mean I'm alright guys do you know
I mean do I not look all right
posted right this is from Julia are you
a flat earther no chance no no are you
do there at Louise strong do you have
any type of routine before writing a
song normally I go into the session we'd
like an idea of lying when I'm like out
and about I might know like different
concepts on the phones they're not
really like specific lyrics but concept
stuff that I want to write now and then
I'm normally go into the session and say
you know here's two or three different
talking points and then we'll kind of
London one this is from at LWT said
walls in a Freaky Friday situation where
you woke up in someone else's body who
would you like to be for a day and have
them inhabit your body it's been a long
day today and that is a crazy question
and funnily enough not something I'd say
it ever thought about and I probably
just wake up in one of the best
footballers bodies and just be amazing
at football probably at Chelsea boot 28
you said you started to read again what
was your favorite book and who's your
favorite fictional character yeah I have
started reading bought at the moment I'm
reading a book about me also there's no
fiction in there so that's that at 91
sh3 tommy said watch your favorite emoji
I don't ever really I'm old [ __ ] don't
use emojis I still do that you know the
two
you call them anyway I don't do about
just posting right onto Instagram now
think so look where was the safety belt
to keep you on that chair interesting
question yeah it was underneath me
jumper that makes your day a lot better
I'd say that why is that with the Q key
wara wara
where's that what are Louie Thomas's
musical inspirations you know naturally
where I grew up in England you know I'm
a massive massive Oasis fans they
definitely had a massive impact on my
life music title going up what a quote
by louis Tomlinson you know you'd have
to ask the fans happy days happy days to
say that Lola said that in an infamous
marijuana video what accent of British
English does Louis Amundson speak
northern and specifically Yorkshire
South Yorkshire I'm from major Donnie
lingo
what is Louie Thomason like in real life
really nice guy submit next Wikipedia he
had a number of jobs including a view
cinema and at Doncaster Rovers football
stadium as a waiter in the hospitality
Suites that's true yeah works at the
cinema for about a year worked Donnie
Rovers for about six months
yeah got me a little extra weight
Tomlinson whose previous football
experience had been to play and run his
own popteen called three Oh shoes had
agreed to play in a charity game at the
keep mount stadium in his hometown of
Doncaster to raise money for the
Bluebell wood charity and offered
offered a deal by professionals oh wow
when they put it like this it makes me
sound incredible
the reality of the situation was I was
in a band with other people who weren't
great players now it's decent that's
about it really
so I always looked like a great footy
player I've always grown up loving
lobster overs I was lucky enough to have
like a contract with them yeah special
timing like submit IMDB trademark
tattoos define cheekbones blue eyes
sounds good to me
next LZ what do you miss about being a
teenager is this something you could
have done different I'm pretty stubborn
that one really different I don't think
best thing about being a teenager is
absolutely zero responsibility what was
the most difficult part while recording
this video and this is a comment on
don't let it break your heart you know
normally on my music videos it's quite
straightforward for me and I'll just you
know perform a little bit walk a little
bit whereas this one have to act but I
was involved in the narrative a little
bit more what are you learning right now
in line well as I said I just started
reading I'm not saying I'm learning to
read because I learnt to read at school
but I'm learning to enjoy ball submit
thank you very much for all your
questions see you soon Cheers